I'm super fired up to be here thank you
so much for having me so there's several
different things running through my mind
but let me let me start with this
because I want to get a sense for the
audience how many people here our
entrepreneurs raise your hand very nice
thank you
quite a bit uh in a working in a small
business very nice
corporate jobs great everyone's like man
[ __ ] awesome that's what I needed okay
let so looking at the hands here's where
I want to go this evening I think the
biggest thing that is on my mind as I
stand here tonight and I appreciate the
wonderful welcome is I including myself
and [ __ ] I spend every minute trying to
understand all of this I think that
everybody in here is under estimating
how special this era is whether you're a
young kid and never knew a non-internet
world whether you're my age 42 or above
and you understood it because we grew up
without it even the people that can
appreciate it because we grew up without
it I don't think a really understanding
that this internet thing is no question
the biggest change in the human race
ever it just is and it's and all the
things we're thinking about whether it's
political or social or financial things
right they just started like everything
that's changing has just started right I
think you know this amazing state has a
lot of pride in some of the great
companies that have come out of it like
in my adulthood not even in my childhood
best fight rose and was eliminated
because of this environment right I'll
be honest with you I don't I mean it's
tough to say but I actually think target
is remarkably vulnerable in an Amazon
Walmart battleworld
and I actually predict pretty
aggressively the target will be bought
by either Amazon or Facebook or Apple or
Google because I think the Internet
companies have to buy retail to compete
with Amazon
so I guess the thing that I think about
is how many 11-year olds are making a
million dollars a year selling slime on
Instagram a lot like like hundreds
let me just like but let's just you know
I think it's like a funny thing and I
can see you guys are picking up what I'm
putting down
hundreds of eleven-year-old make a
million dollars a year selling slime at
the same token the top 1% earners in
America financially start at four
hundred thousand four hundred something
thousand a year right so you you hear
about Instagram or an eleven-year-old
making a million right like it's crazy
to me what runs through all the smbs
small businesses and entrepreneurs in
here like a million is like waking up
like making a million or having a
million dollar business that's just kind
of like normal like the way this room
this state this country the game thinks
about building a million dollar business
is like oh one and every other one of us
50 percent of us are gonna do that yet
its 1% and there's a real real
disconnect between the reality of what's
happening all the opportunity and so
what I think is happening is this
extremism much like our social issues
where we're starting to really go in
opposite directions there's this
extremism of yes there are hundreds of
11 year-olds making a million [ __ ]
dollars a year making slime selling it
on Instagram yet 99% of people that
raised two million dollars in capital
for their startup to make the uber of
[ __ ] Pizza Delivery are going to fail
and so I'm trying to think about what am
I talking about what's driving me and I
think the thing that's grounding me is
in this ridiculous change in our society
things like 15 years ago
if you dated on the internet and dated
somebody you met on the internet that
that was you were weird and a loser and
it was taboo and now every single person
dates through the internet and swipes
left and right 24/7 or slides into the
DNA
right or do you know crazy
uber is as an early investor boomers
insane uber or lyft or whatever you want
literally if I stood up here and said
guys in 15 years you're gonna want your
thirteen-year-old daughter to go into a
stranger's car cuz you're gonna think
that's safer than her driving with your
friend like literally in high net-worth
towns across america now on the 16th or
17th or 15th birthday the gift of choice
if you're in a rich area is unlimited
uber for the kid like kids don't want
cars the kids in the suburbs are not
getting licenses if they're in a high
net-worth and you know environment
because they'd rather just have
unlimited uber and parents actually and
probably correctly think it's safer for
their sixteen-year-old daughter to go
into strange 40 year old men cars
multiple times a day I mean it but I
would have never been able to sell you
on that if this was ten years ago and
I'm like let's do startup ideas and I
pitched you on that you would have
laughed me out of the room I know
because I laughed the founders of uber
out of the room when they were like what
if everybody could get a limo on their
iPhone I was like yeah like 1% of rich
people like it never saw it playing out
the way it did and so I don't know I
think it's a very interesting time but
what's interesting to me about it is as
the world's changing as people watching
video games like more people watch
people play video games than watch
people play baseball right and like
that's just real and by the way back to
it just started like there's no base but
Bryce Harper and Mike Trout combined on
their best day are one-tenth of as
famous as ninja is two 14 year olds in
America and so like but that's not what
we grew up with and so like all these
things that are happening guys Amy see
NBC and CBS are finished they're done
like remember when four years ago you
had one show on Netflix that you liked
but then you watched cable
now you have Netflix and there's one
show on cable or regular TV do you
understand when all the sports go to
Netflix and Amazon like Amazon has
bought the rights to Englishmen football
bait about you know proper football
soccer [ __ ] you know tennis got like
Amazon's gonna be bidding for the NFL
who lose gonna have hockey Google and
Apple are gonna have basketball like
you're never gonna turn on to 4 or 5 or
7 ever and so in this world like think
about like nothing we believe in or use
YouTube the iPhone Netflix Facebook none
of that existed 15 years ago nothing
that our entire society is running on
who was not alive 15 years ago raise
your hand
good we were all here I'm a little
pissed at my 13 year old fans didn't
come out tonight but but everything we
run on guys almost everybody here
remembers the world priests mark phone
like you couldn't like like it's just
five minutes ago that you're like the
internet on your phone we struggle with
things parents all the time when
snapchat blew up three four years ago
parents were like Gary but I don't want
my kid on snapchat I'm like you do know
your son has Safari and can type in jizz
hut calm right
like you're worried about the one floozy
13 year old in the [ __ ] state and the
dude's got porn that is [ __ ]
fingertips and that's what I think a lot
about which is nobody here is actually
quantified what's really happened here
for example there's a term in start-up
land or a business world called the last
mile it's this big debate of like how
we're all gonna get everything delivered
to us within an hour right is it going
to be Amazon is it going to be uber is
it gonna be post mate what I don't think
people understand is 7-eleven is
actually out of business in the next 15
years 20 years because of the last mile
you need deodorant or a [ __ ] 20 ounce
Mountain Dew
you're gonna press a button it's gonna
be in your [ __ ] house or office in a
second so what I don't what I think I've
done really well in my career by
launching a wine business on the
Internet in 1996 when people told me the
Internet itself was a fad or buying
Google AdWords when nobody even knew
what a search engine really was or when
I started a wine show on YouTube in the
first six months that existed or went
all-in on social media when everybody
[ __ ] on social media I was there I
remember what everybody thought about
Twitter and how stupid it was or that
Facebook was a college thing blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah is that we are
bad at understanding the present and the
future and we love to put the past on a
pedestal somebody said to me yesterday
Gary but what about looking a man in the
eyes when you talk to him I'm like what
about it like that means you don't think
people should write letters or talk on
the phone we put the past on a pedestal
we demonize the current and the future
and so in all these changes in all of
this stuff that is going on the thing
that's most fascinating to me and the
thing that I want to talk to you about
is that this like doing the right thing
and gratitude and honor and all this
propaganda that I push is actually more
valuable than ever because let me tell
you what the Internet's going
and I've been saying this for a long
time and I feel like people finally are
starting to believe me because of the
me2 movement and many other things the
internet is going to expose all of us
our society has been groomed and has
lived in the shadows of our society our
institutions our beliefs this has all
been sustained by the darkness like all
those [ __ ] in the second section I
can't see you appreciate your darkest
[ __ ] when people yell at me I had this
woman yelling at me friends she wasn't
yelling evil she was yelling at me over
dinner about like how this internet
thing is scary and it sucks and this and
that and she's an incredible activists
for all women's rights and all this
other thing I'm like you do understand
that your media that you're putting on a
pedestal the New York Times and NBC is
the reason all this bad stuff was able
to happen yeah Kathleen that's exactly
right
when five or six old white guys control
the media a lot of stuff doesn't hit
daylight when we control the media it
gets a lot harder
let me give you a news alert Russia
didn't make you do anything it didn't it
meaning if you're a good person a bad
person voted democrat or republican did
did it to you do you I have zero
interest in debating politics with
anybody these days because everyone's
untilled I just want everybody know the
Russians didn't hack your [ __ ] brain
like the like you didn't let go in
saying I'm gonna vote for Hillary and
vote for Donald or the other way around
they that's not what happened what
happened is you believe in what you want
to believe technology is exposing us
it's not changing us and so what's
happening where does this all go what I
want you to do more than anything is
understand the following it has never
been a better time in the human race
ever to actually just go all in on you
the thing that I've realized all these
chess moves go to is judgement is the
poison in the system we are all doing so
much based on our worries or our
pandering to judgment we we buy things
we can't afford because we want to look
good to everybody else
parents quietly subsidize kids lives in
their 20s because they want other
parents that think their kids doing well
but what they're actually doing is
creating a fake environment for that kid
and eliminating their self-esteem and
then that kid becomes entitled and
everybody's [ __ ] pissed the kid the
parent and it gets real [ __ ] up real
fast kids out here posturing like
they're an entrepreneur but mommy's
paying for the gym pass
[Laughter]
so there's a ton of [ __ ] going on and
what I think you know I sit and I watch
and I watch and I watch and I ask why is
this working why have I been putting out
content for a decade but the last 18
months has worked more better different
am I better at understanding Instagram
and podcasts and YouTube or is the
message that I'm talking finding the
right timing is it important is it right
is it tried-and-true are we ready for it
we not what's happening and here's
what's happening we are in a remarkable
time for all the things you may be
worried about left right up down there's
never been a better time to be alive in
the human race than right now
medicine life expectancy poverty every
issue we have better you know the best
people to talk about what's going on in
America or 90 year olds they [ __ ] on
everybody they're like she thinks it's
bad ah [ __ ] my eye this woman made me
laugh sorry it's like 92 year old woman
stopped me in the speech and I keep
doing what you're doing I'm like thank I
mean she looked like 190 I was like
thank you I got talked in for a second
she's like and by the way these women
and she's wrong but it was still funny
she goes these woman [ __ ] if I didn't
have somebody grab my ass every day in
the office I was pissed I think I get it
I was like I get it I was like don't say
that in public she's like [ __ ] public
I was like man 92 is some gangster [ __ ]
I'm obsessed with practicality I'm
obsessed with practicality
people think I'm a destructor or you
know nostra darling predictor or right
I'm practical Facebook and Instagram ads
are grossly underpriced if you go home
tonight and Google how to run Instagram
story ads and learn how to do that and
then make a video or picture and runs
Instagram story ads for whatever you're
trying to do in life become the mayor
here sell some peanuts
kombucha get people to sign up for your
[ __ ] you know track team I don't care
what I don't know what the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] comes from I don't think you can
sign people up for a track team anyway
nonetheless an Instagram story ad will
work better than anything else you can
do if you care about people 15 to 55 15
to 45 if you care about people 30 to 75
Facebook works better than anything like
all your dreams whatever that may be
simple dreams like making four hundred
dollars more a month so you can save it
and take your family to Walt Disney this
year all your dreams like the amount of
people that are affected by making two
hundred dollars more a month is
staggering the fact that I know that if
you literally stop listening to me right
now took out your phone went to
Craigslist went to the for sale section
clicked on the free section within the
for sale section took your [ __ ] car
got up left in the middle my keynote and
picked up eight things went home took
one picture on your [ __ ] phone not
like [ __ ] old days where the [ __ ]
phone he'd take the discount and putting
the [ __ ] computer no not that which
is oh by the way the old days you know
11 years ago and no just take a picture
of the [ __ ] thing and post it on
Facebook marketplace and post it for 20
to 80 dollars that literally in the next
48 hours you would have $200 more I'm
obsessed with practicality everything I
talk about feels so real it just might
take 11 years and a lot of people don't
have 11 years
they don't have 11 years because we're
not wanting to put in the work to be
happy for the rest of their life they'd
rather complain they'd rather blame
somebody else the biggest thing that's
happening in America and the world is a
lack of accountability you want to
really know what the [ __ ] happening
here a lack of accountability and so for
me for me forget about it because I am
doing more of than normal for who knows
why undertones of the politic thing it's
if you sit here tonight and you are not
completely [ __ ] pumped about your life
it's up to you to change that but if
this was 1987 and I mean this son
everything I love I wouldn't have a lot
of energy for you I wouldn't even stand
up here and talk about it I wouldn't
have the audacity to [ __ ] you that
you could do something about it cuz it
wasn't practical who's got a smartphone
raise your hand actually who doesn't
come on dude seriously in the yellow you
don't please come up here I need to see
you
you got I need to see what this man is
[Applause]
get up here bro
right over there hurry up dude this is
amazing thank you hello how are you
what's your name rod rod so rod where
are you from let's clap it up you do not
have a smartphone you have a flip phone
[Applause]
so Thursday afternoon you leaving work
like you don't have a phone right and
now you once had a smartphone and you've
started fighting the system yes why are
you fighting the system because I
believe talking to people and getting to
know people is a lot more so real quick
though doesn't that mean that some other
human has to exist that doesn't have a
phone guys this is a national treasure
let's clap it up with its pioneer
kenderson that's incredible [ __ ] rare
that is a writ left like literally you
could bring a [ __ ] alien for Mars
right now and I would look at that as
more common than this incredible
gentleman if you're everybody but rod
and you have this you literally can do
anything the fact that this is just
where [ __ ] gets crazy to me the fact
that this is more powerful of a computer
than what Ronald Reagan had running the
free world is [ __ ] crazy right like
it's crazy you could do anything like
literally every person here lay up
unless all of you do it because then I
would [ __ ] up the Craigslist supply and
demand curve but everybody here
literally could make $1,000 more you
know I came up with this 2017 flip
challenge where I talked about yard
sales and thrift stops and dollar stores
and it really helped a lot of people
like just people on welfare or needed
fifty bucks more it was really amazing
but then of course you always have
somebody [ __ ] looking for an excuse
and they're like well what if you have
no money you know and I'm a really weird
[ __ ] I'm like I would jump in and be
like yo pants 87 what do you mean by
none like you talk to me like you know
and it would go into this and so like
people would troll it and then all of a
sudden I was like wait a minute I don't
want to hear that anymore I'm gonna
figure out what happens if you actually
have no money 0 so this whole Craigslist
to Facebook thing is remarkable it's
free you literally go to somebody's
house they give it to you happily cuz
they don't want an old TV anymore or a
hammock or a [ __ ] trampoline or no
they're usually big things they need
[ __ ] trucks but that's good because
I've been here for about 20 minutes
there's a lot of [ __ ] trucks here
so you're set and and
and listing on Facebook is free like
this is like not even like eBay like
dollar list this all free and people can
make one hundred a thousand two thousand
dollars a month if they're willing to
eat [ __ ] see cause it takes [ __ ] to like
always be on your phone and be on free
when the person lists it it takes [ __ ]
to be in a suburb of Maine towns like
this where you might have to drive fifty
five minutes to pick up that thing and
there's gas costs in this and that and I
get that it takes [ __ ] to do that it's
funny this really is caught on there's
like a whole mean going on the internet
right now because there's a bunch of
people literally riding on subways with
like couches there's like this whole
viral thing going on it some of my fans
know it's me and they're like it's
[ __ ] Gary me and like where I'm going
with this little story is I'm so
flabbergasted that the excuses have been
eliminated by the internet see what I
love about the Internet is it doesn't
know who you are
it doesn't care where you came from what
nationality are gender income level if
you're just willing to work your [ __ ]
face off you can get there the problem
is there's something that I'm very
fascinated with which is called
entitlement and it goes into the thing
of judgment a lot of people have emailed
me and said Gary this is working but a
problem I don't have a car I have to
take the bus I did what you said and I
did have this chair with me on the bus
but everybody was looking at me and it
was it's super powerful because the [ __ ]
we worry about in third grade is the
[ __ ] we worry about today like I
literally wrote him back I was like yo
you are in a place in your life where
you need 20 bucks right like really the
stranger on the bus is your [ __ ]
problem
like like you should be pumped you
should be proud like document that [ __ ]
right and so I'm I'm thinking a lot
about privilege in a lot of ways but
I've come to realize the ultimate
privilege privilege is being right up
here to me if I could have any dream my
dream would be that we could map the
human DNA and figure out what
self-esteem is and pump it into
everybody's [ __ ] body 24/7 365
because we need to actually have
self-esteem you have empathy for others
you don't care what they think about you
you do it gets really quiet here and you
do and I can't implore this audience
enough to realize that Facebook and
Instagram right now is so remarkably
underpriced and its ability to change
the outcome of your business your dreams
your mission your name and that a lot of
people here have opinions about what to
do on Facebook and Instagram how good or
bad does it work but you've never used
it you've never really run a Facebook ad
you've never really run an Instagram add
you have opinions you pontificate but
you're not a practitioner and so if I
could anything today
it would be to encourage people to go
home and Google how to run Facebook Ads
how to run Instagram ads because that
will absolutely change your game and if
how many people here are running
Facebook or Instagram ads raise your
hands let me tell you something else
raise them higher just curious
a lot which is great and how many of
those people feel like it's successful
and they're happy with what's going on
stand up actually stand up
you could sell that bottle for 10 cents
here's my thing for everybody who's not
or and let's be honest right now keep
standing if you don't mind how many
people here this is very fair because
it's happened to me so I want to make
you feel safe but it it's important to
me how many people have here have run
Facebook or Instagram ads and it didn't
work raise your hands and notice how
many that are standing are doing it as
well I think about this all the time the
ROI thank you just you can said thank
you the ROI of a basketball you've some
of you heard me say this for LeBron it's
a billion dollars for me it's zero just
because you didn't have a successful ad
campaign on Facebook or Instagram
doesn't mean it doesn't work it means
you suck I'm serious it means you sucked
like if you don't run a successful cab
campaign right now on Facebook and
Instagram in the way that's so under
priced you actually really suck now
here's the good news a lot of people run
ads that are self-serving the reason so
many things aren't working for people is
because it's good for you not for the
other person nobody wants your $897
[ __ ] ebook that's why your [ __ ]
Facebook ad didn't work and that's the
problem not Facebook and so I really
really really want to implore people to
understand that I sit here with a lot of
business regret because when my dad's
business grew from three to sixty
million it should have been from three
to two hundred fifty million but I
didn't run enough Google Ads I figured
it out I hit pay dirt
and guess what somebody bought
beachfront property in Malibu and only
bought one house when she could have
reported fourth and she regrets it for
the rest of time somebody was thinking
for gold and found some and then just
left cuz he felt like we were good it
ran out and then watched ten more years
of gold being found on and on and on I
hit hard on Google when it first popped
but I didn't spend enough because I was
a kid and I didn't realize how special
that moment was and that moment went
away buying the word Cabernet and Merlot
and Pinot Grigio and Bordeaux and Napa
Valley and wine
wines and wine gifts and missin at they
were five and ten cents a click and I
bought them all and nobody knew what the
[ __ ] was happening there was millions of
people on Google and I got bigger than
Haskell's and Sam's and sherry Lehman's
and wine club and everybody was confused
why that's what's happening right now on
Facebook and Instagram I'm telling you
the [ __ ] truth I'm giving it to you
and 98% of you will not do anything
about it that [ __ ] with me heavy I'm do
literally giving it to you here and
you're saying yeah and to me when people
ask me why the [ __ ] do you give away all
your best [ __ ] that's where you could
make all your money it's because 98% of
you are not gonna do anything about it
and for the 2% when I see you in line
and you tell me I changed your life or
this and that that admiration feels
phenomenal and I still get to make all
the money cuz 98% of you [ __ ] faces
are not gonna do any thing about it you
need to ask yourself tonight why it's
more interesting to dwell and complain
and come up with excuses than actually
be happy I'll save you time your mom
[ __ ] you up
so cool right or your dad or your older
brother or some circumstance here's my
big thing I'm looking around and even
for the geezers in here you're all
living for another 50 [ __ ] years
minimum there's people and hit crunch I
mean good I know I know you're like [ __ ]
awesome right cuz when you were kids
you're like 60 [ __ ] it now now right now
but you know what's crazy now it is not
like how many people here under 30 all
of you outside of like devastate by at
scale almost all of you get to a hundred
hundred ten easy
that's [ __ ] nuts you're you're
freaking out you turn 30 and you were
[ __ ] living for another 90 [ __ ]
years you're like I don't have my [ __ ]
together I'm like you [ __ ] start a
dick I'm about to make this video about
18 it's gonna be called 18 20 to 30
these are the three ages that everybody
just gets [ __ ] for some reason at 18
22 and 30 you have to every [ __ ]
thing figured out and these [ __ ] 59
year old parents are like you gotta get
your [ __ ] together
and they still have no clue what the
[ __ ] they're doing
I didn't mean while somebody at 15 knows
what they're doing right to me this age
think it's like sports like is
experience better because I don't know I
saw 18 year old LeBron and Kobe dominate
right this is a talent game this is a
self-awareness game this is like do your
[ __ ] together up here game are you
letting somebody else dictate your
happiness who how what and it's all
interesting to me because it all makes
sense and it's right but then this came
along you know one of the reasons I put
a lot of pressure on the parenting thing
is I have got really educated by old
people hanging out in retirement homes
and 70 80 90 year olds here's what
happens kids do things to make their
parents happy because they don't want
confrontation and they want it to be
good they go be a lawyer or a doctor
because they don't want to fight or have
a bad relationship the problem is then
they have a 50-year bad relationship
because resentment and regret take over
I don't want parents and kids to fight
or I'm not trying to get into people's
business I just know it's way better for
you to fight for three or four years and
then have a great relationship then get
along fakely for nine and then not like
each other for life
by the way this whole notion of like you
can do anything and all this stuff let
me just tell you it's stupid hard
reality is most of you are just average
ly talented right like you're not gonna
over index in anything too crazy here's
the good news this is not about how much
money you make or how talented you are
this is about being happy
everybody here regardless of how [ __ ]
talented they are in making money or art
or what-have-you
has [ __ ] that they're super into you
love Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles your
whole life could be about [ __ ]
Michelangelo
it could and here's what really [ __ ]
with me in this internet age you can
have a podcast around teenage Ninja
Turtles
you could buy Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle memorabilia on Craigslist and
Facebook and Etsy and then flip it on a
different platform because you're so
[ __ ] knowledgeable cuz that's the
pizza eating [ __ ] Leonardo that I'm
just fascinated about what you happens
when you go all in on your passion
you're committed to it and you use the
infrastructure of this you living your
life for 80 years as the [ __ ] Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle expert this is
getting funnier to me by the second
making 83k a year in ads on your
podcasts the flip some miraculous reason
somebody paid you two thousand dollars
to go to a bush-league comic-con thing
that person making sixty-two thousand a
year being the [ __ ] TMT [ __ ]
expert versus them making seventy seven
thousand a year being an admin in a
company where they hate their life
nine-to-five that Delta is something I
will go to the grave on because it is
what I want to articulate to everybody
the the unbelievable level of
practicality to do [ __ ] around stuff you
like and here's the big part how many
people under 40 let me just start with
this group if you just really took what
I'm talking about
became an expert of Facebook and
Instagram really understood the fact
that you could take a leap for two years
move back in home move in together cut
your expenses I don't give a [ __ ] the
fact that you can do that for two or
three years and if it doesn't work out
you can go back
to getting a job that's nuts
that's nuts and so we have to understand
what's going on
why is Toys R Us going out of business
why are all these things happening it's
happening because the internet is eating
up our society why do we have such big
opportunities because everybody here can
start a competitor to coca-cola which
used to take fifty million dollars
because you have to buy in to Albertsons
and to Safeway and Target and you had to
make it and you have to [ __ ] market
it on television and now it costs
$200,000 can you make some you slap it
on Amazon 3pl you run some Instagram
influencer ads and you're in the game
it's crazy it's absolutely crazy how's
the painting coming along look at this
is this amazing
[Applause]
you have to listen I'm desperate to get
you to go home and rethink the whole
thing I'm looking to speak to two people
tonight I'm being very serious
I can't wait to the QA you can get you
can get me into a different direction I
know he'll jump out here and we'll give
him a big shout-out for putting this
together he'll take me in a different
direction he wants to talk about the
macro situation of this town
aka a lot of money's coming and you're
all gonna act like idiots you can ask me
about whatever the [ __ ] you want but I'm
telling you what I'm really looking for
my mission my selfish moment where I'm
going with this talk is I'm looking to
talk to two of you to you they're gonna
go home go deep for 60 hours over the
next three or four days actually take
that jump rely listen you all do know
what I'm talking about is exactly like
starting to ride a bike kissing a boy or
girl or starting to swim all of those
things were scary as [ __ ] do you know
many people here stood on the edge of a
pool for like 19 hours in their life and
then you do it you're like what the [ __ ]
was I doing
that's what's crazy about those things
those are big right not kissing somebody
that like when you're a kid like that's
big this is your life and it's the same
game
it's that normal in the Internet age to
jump around stuff you like the best part
is you can do both you can work your
nine-to-five still pay your bills you
like cool Gary this is all very
ideological but I have rent I have some
loans
I got this [ __ ] cool keep it what's
crazy about the internet I'm like what
we grew up with whereas if you wanted to
open up your store your dream store you
know you had to be there and so by the
time you got home at 7:00 you couldn't
do that the fact that you can do this
from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning
until it means something enough to give
you the courage to jump off the other
thing this is just practical the dream
of being happy and living your life has
actually become practical you're sitting
on the information but because it wasn't
like that for the last 300 years you
can't wrap your head around it and
because it seems so crazy the idea of
doing it and nothing happens for six
months makes you feel like it wasn't
meant to be and you get out because you
were built and groomed within a school
environment the end the only reason I'm
successful is because I got D's and F's
and I didn't listen I mean it it's how I
see things differently you need somebody
else to have already done it you need to
see the path I don't like paths
I need blank slates this is a blank
slate do you understand that almost
every single person in their basement
garage and closets are sitting between 2
and 11 thousand dollars worth of [ __ ] in
their house that they can pote like
there's so much going on to me that I
can't wrap my head around that that so
many people here can build a 50 to 500
thousand dollar a year business on
Amazon just by going on websites in
China buying something and then realist
on Amazon that my parents and I had
dinner in New York and we had this nice
dinner and we got coming out and our
waitress ran a fancy place and the
waitress ran out and grabbed me and said
thank you so much and she said my
fiancee was out of a job for 19 months
depressed doing drugs saw one of your
instrument videos and a year later on
Amazon is making 1.3 million dollars a
year for me to me this is [ __ ] nuts
and so I'm just desperately trying to
find the two people here that are not
happy enough whatever that may be to
realize this internet thing is big and
like look if you're happy like really
happy do you don't do anything go home
to me play nine hours a fortnight I
don't give a [ __ ] but if you're not you
need to desperately figure out what's
actually happening here these shocking
things in our society in the world and
big companies going out of business and
shocking results in elections and all
these different things it's happening
because of the internet you should get
your piece cuz it's a long long tail you
should get your piece and you have to
figure out whether it's selling or a
service or whatever it may be
like what do you like like what do you
like because the only way you're gonna
work the 16 17 hours on a weekend that
will actually get you there in two years
is if you love retro clothes if you love
strawberry [ __ ] jam if you love rare
Rod Carew artifacts
that's the only race that was a good one
if that's the only way right that's the
only way and so I am super excited about
the time that we're living in I love
what's going on I love that the big
companies are losing I love that the
establishment is in trouble I love it
because I think it's gonna be better I
think we're all gonna be happier I
really do
and so when Best Buy goes out of
business I don't see that negativity I
see that as an opportunity I love that
people like oh this money shouldn't go
out of business best might put people
out of business best buy put people out
to business everyone's like this is
unfair Walmart like target target put
people out of business
how are you confused by this all of a
sudden this was the moment to stop
capitalism like plus targets here and
the point I appreciate that and the good
point to that is this part target put
people out of business ironically if you
really play out my thesis the people
that are gonna put target out of
business are back to the small people
you like that look I don't care that the
small wins are the big wins
I think it's all fair I think it's gonna
be super cool like I could care less but
I know it's true small merchants
downtown's then we move to the suburbs
supermarkets big-box retailers they
killed it cool now we're gonna be able
to kill it because you're gonna make up
somebody in here is gonna actually put
two and two together go home do work and
in seven years is gonna be selling a
million dollars a year of peanuts on
Amazon and that's what chips away at
planters that's what chips away at
Walmart and CBS and that's what chips
away at 7-eleven you are gonna regret
you made a big mistake coming here
tonight I'm gonna tell you why you made
a big big mistake coming here tonight
I'm telling you why I'm putting pressure
on you to do something with your life
everything I'm telling you is about to
happen and will happen over the next 50
years and in 31 years when you did
nothing about it I'm gonna find you make
fun of you let's do it is right like who
just curious : to me a little bit
happier raise your [ __ ] hand so to me
news alert your presidents not gonna
[ __ ] do it for you you're gonna do it
for you and that is the most interesting
[ __ ] to me of all time this internet
thing is big it's real big it'll be
bigger than we all thought the robots
are gonna kill every one of our children
but until then let's have some [ __ ]
fun
if you judge Facebook or Instagram if
you do what rot robbed by the way I
respect his point of view but if you
judge this and you use it in your
business or financial life based on how
you view it from a social stands
like you know what would have been
gangster about him he's like I don't
have one but I have a huge Shopify
business on the side to me the fact that
you're not doing Facebook or Instagram
or YouTube out of a social point of view
at the detriment of your business and
happiness and opportunity is nuts
because you're mad that people aren't
talking to each other in real life
you're leaving opportunity on the table
for yourself it's not a good idea I
don't know how to put it now if you're
happy once again
I'm always worried when I talk about
like I am NOT talking to anybody who's
happy but the opportunity is substantial
and we a lot of times impose our points
of view like you don't you want your kid
running outside more
so that's you're not running Facebook
Ads I mean it's nuts I mean and and let
me tell you why this is so important you
have to understand why this is so
important I run a company called
vaynermedia chase and Budweiser and
Pepsi and Johnson & Johnson the biggest
companies in the world they are not
listening to me my friends this is
SuperDuper important let me tell you
what happened to little ol me with
Google I knew what was going on I was
running the ads I didn't spend enough
and then everybody else figured it out
they started spending more money and the
word cabernet went from 15 cents a click
to $6 and when it cost $6 and only one
out of every 50 people converted on the
website it didn't become mathematically
worth it for me anymore to run it got it
Facebook and Instagram cost four five
six seven dollars to have your picture
or video get in front of a thousand
people that you want in four years after
I'm done commencing chase and Budweiser
and Target to spend eighty percent of
their money on Facebook instead of five
because you know not one [ __ ] person
here watches a commercial outside of
Superbowl
those ads to get front of a 48 year old
female that's in two frisbees in
Minnesota are gonna go from six bucks to
82 and your little [ __ ] frisbee
startup that started tonight is gonna
not be growing as fast everything I'm
telling you is about to go away in the
next four years
not the thesis of the internet but we're
gonna need something to come along like
a Facebook like a Google and take it
from somebody who lived in between
Facebook and Google those were six
lonely years when nothing was a deal
it's a deal it's in your face I sit with
these executives and they spend 45
minutes telling me that Facebook is
tearing the American [ __ ] democracy
and this is the worst thing and we need
to regulate it and Facebook's too
powerful and then we're done
then pontificating their politics and we
get into business and I try to convince
them to spend more money on Facebook and
like but it doesn't it doesn't work for
us and I'm like let me get this straight
you think this platform is so powerful
that it can tear down America but it's
not powerful enough to sell an extra
six-pack of beer you [ __ ] idiot
you have 48 months to buy up property in
Manhattan for a nickel on a dollar
you're more than welcome not to the end
please take what I said tonight
seriously this is the single best land
grab
I've seen in the last 20 years and the
single best one in my opinion since this
country switched from radio jesus
[ __ ] rice I'm kidding kid
since this country it was such a good
one it was quiet - it's the transition
to a mobile-first world with Facebook
and Instagram is the biggest switch
since we switched from radio to
television and Bob Hope and Lucille Ball
and coca-cola and Budweiser can tell you
how that worked out real good and so
I'll be doing my Bob Hope Lucille Ball
thing over here I really like you to
either figure it out if you want to be
Lucille Ball or coca-cola or some little
version of it because unlike television
that had you know three channels back
that with 12 hours of programming this
thing is unlimited so you know what that
means that means everybody here can get
their 60 K they're 90 k there 100 K
there 400 K there's 700 K long tail long
tail everybody used to want their 15
minutes of fame right now everybody's
famous - 15 people got it or 1,500 or
15,000 you're letting this moment slip
I'm watching you let this moment slip
and I came here tonight to wake you the
[ __ ] up get woke and address this
ridiculous ridiculous opportunity the
best one you may ever have in your
entire [ __ ] life thank you
[Applause]
[Music]